on kobe bryant's shot making and
footwork
cunningham off the bounce got to the rim
and got the layup well so they moved
green off of kate cunningham detroit
basketball okay cunningham you heard the
noise crossed the big man up
cunningham with a couple of buckets and
the steal here defensively
and he put green in the weight room made
the dime
and flexed on him a little bit i see
fishing move
and then the second time oh i'm sorry
did you say big ball
big boy basketball through the houston
rockets
looking at a 30 to 27 ball game right
now with 7 20 to go
come on there's the three ball that's a
jalen green
is there then him with the drive mr
green oh you've settled in but he's
known cade and he's known jail in a long
time cade comes right back next play
nice adjustment
cunningham staring down green the number
two pick
oh he took his ankles there knocked down
the three
oh he got a little bit of smoke
mark jones you enjoyed this screen was
not effective but that's all right jalen
green gets caught cheating he pulls it
back oh stop it now don't send him in
that direction mr cunningham
really good awareness of the clock
play going nowhere right they're playing
without a point guard so christopher's
acting like that's a nice boot wow
cunningham
which way to spin based on where he's
feeling that defender on his back
deep three butter
lamb
locked up by hayes
green for three
jalen green
but jalen
does not lack for confidence i mean what
a striking difference right jalen on the
catch ready